التصعيد أه في
ذهابًا وإيابًا لإطلاق الصواريخ بين
إسرائيل وغزة ترى الصور على
اللهب الأيسر
في تل أبيب ويأتي هذا بعد
انهيار برج مكون من 13 طابقًا هناك في
غزة
بعد غارة جوية إسرائيلية
انضممنا إليها الآن.  CNN's ben wiedemann
هو في القدس من أجلنا فيما
يحدث
بشكل جيد ما لديك هو
تكثيف حقيقي لهذه الضربات
والضربات المضادة
بين إسرائيل وغزة مؤخرًا
بالطبع
وابل ضخم أطلق من غزة إلى
تل أبيب
هناك تقارير عن وجود حافلة  ضرب
جنوب تل أبيب
في مدينة هولندا مع
إصابة ثلاثة أشخاص على الأقل
هناك عدد القتلى في غزة وآخر ما رأيناه
من هذا ذهابًا وإيابًا كان 28
وما هو واضح هو أن هذا التصعيد
مستمر هناك لا
يبدو.  أن يكون أي جهد لشراء إما
الفلسطينيين أو الإسرائيليين
للسيطرة على ما يبدو
أنه موجة من العنف التي
تكثف فقط يبدو أن كلا الجانبين
يتبع سيناريو رأيناه من قبل في عام 201  4
كنت هنا في القدس ثم في غزة
عندما أه كانت لديك
احتجاجات حاشدة هنا في القدس
أدت إلى إطلاق صواريخ وهجمات أخرى
من غزة
أدت إلى حرب دموية طويلة
جدًا ولا تظهر في هذه المرحلة
إذا شاركت في الحدث
بالنظر إلى أحداث
الأيام القليلة الماضية ، هذا ما نتجه إليه
مرة أخرى. كيف يقارن هذا
بما رأيناه في 2014
ما فاجأني هو
سرعة التصعيد ، فقد استمر التصعيد في 2014
لمدة  أسابيع ، ما
رأيناه حقًا في الـ 72 ساعة الماضية
هو أن الاحتجاجات هنا في القدس
على إخلاء المنازل بسبب إجراءات الشرطة التي
تحاول تقييد وصول
الفلسطينيين
إلى جبل الحرم الشريف خلفي
قد تصاعدت بسرعة إلى هذه
الهجمات والتصدي لـ-  الهجمات بين
غزة وإسرائيل بطريقة لم
تكن كذلك
في عام 2014 ، كانت أكثر تدريجيًا
ولا نرى أنك تعلم أننا سمعنا
هدوء الولايات المتحدة يدعو إلى الهدوء
ولكن هذه الدعوات للهدوء حقًا  لا
يبدو أنه يتردد صداها
كثيرًا في الوقت الحالي حيث يبدو أن كلا
الجانبين يأخذانه
يبدو خطًا متشددًا للغاية في الوقت
الحالي وكما قلت لا أحد يتراجع في
هذه المرحلة